vous est venue cette idée de faire une
grève de la faim je vais vous poser une
question
oui si je ne l'avais pas fait grève de
la faim est ce que je serai là non c'est
vrai parce qu'on n'aurait pas été au
courant
je suis tellement violent ouais je me
suis dit ben tu vas violente est ton
corps et ton esprit on voit on va dire
que c'est quelque chose de sérieux et
les rédactions de presse vont venir te
voir hier entre hier et aujourd'hui j'ai
eu à peu près 40 interviews tous les
milieux ont repris les médias de presse
écrite ont entouré prix bien sûr sur les
réseaux sociaux ça a été c'est un énorme
bosse c'est une avalanche et bien sûr
moi enfin je suis pas je suis pas je
suis pas fait pour ça moi je suis un
simple boule anglais moi je suis dans
mon fournil pratiquement 15 heures par
jour voire plus je n'appartiens pas à
votre j'appartiens pas aux orateurs
j appartiens pas moins chiant manuel fut
un pur manuel c'est pas mais enfin je
devrais pas combattre c'est pas ma vie
de vrai que combat pour mon entreprise
depuis 24 ans mais je ne lis jamais
pensé combattre pour quelqu'un en fait
ce n'est ces gamins est arrivé ce gamin
mais oui mais vous avez dès janvier il
avait des enfants ses fins je suis en
train d'adopter d'accord et j'ai ça vous
l'avez considère un peu comme un mets un
fils tout tout tout mes employés sont
font partie de la famille il suffit de
regarder regarder son soutien qu'il est
là aujourd'hui
s'il devait repartir seriez dans quel
état je le présume que je vis ici de
deux de faire la grève de la faim
jusqu'au 26 et je travaille toujours
d'accord qui est toujours orpheline
vous pouvez pas l'adopter je dis une
bêtise patatras c'est non mais on ya
pensé à l'adopter on ya pensé j'ai
encore comme celle déjà en train de dima
ma fille je ne peux pas être partout
mais
c'est une idée on m'a lancé sur les
réseaux sociaux bien surveillé cher
soyez prêts à l'adopter pas pourquoi pas
il a envie lui à bas après il vous
considère est là et c'est un grand
taiseux ylang autant un grand sourire
qu'ils étaient eux mêmes donc ils super
discret que jamais on l'entend fourni
est-ce qu'il parle français
oui comment encore mieux que moi ça
c'est important pour l'intégration mais
il n'y a pas eu d'intégration il était
bien intégrée des qualités d'arrivée
alors aujourd'hui on va attendre la
session vous allez faire la grève de la
faim jusqu'au 26 janvier
alors je vais essayer vous avez essayé
mais ça se passe plutôt par les
relations parce que c'est vrai que
j'avais déjà fait un petit problème de
santé oui vous avez vous avez pas peur
pour votre santé vous fait suivre
willimon infirmière qui vient tous les
trois jours mais comment si si je le
fais pas tu sais qu'il le fait on va le
regarder partir comme tous les autres
moyens dossier qui est un dossier de 2-2
autres alors il y en a bien plus un mais
deux autres apprentis en fit yens 1 kg 1
et dans un garage le le garagiste
ils furent heureux quand il a téléphoné
et pas de problème c'est à n'y a pas de
problème on comprend le monsieur à 50
ans au plus près il est tellement
attaché à ce gamin qui pleurer en me
disant la préfecture ne veut rien faire
le maire ne veut rien faire vous avez eu
le courage c'est pas du courage de faire
une grève de la faim pour un pour faire
bouger les choses pour faire bouger les
choses
j'ai un certain mental et voilà un
levier mais c'est une évidence pour moi
non